hey y'all it's a Sunday sidetrack yeah I
thought it was Monday man I woke up I
was think about going to get the mail
what time it was and then I was going
like man why isn't anybody posting yeah
the man's looking about mine my newsfeed
on YouTube and I went I realized [ __ ]
mess [ __ ] a Sunday it's Sunday
everyone's hungover
yeah I thought was Monday I'm not even
though we did drink a lot today is a day
yeah it's day day yeah I mean I still
have to kind of keep track cuz I have to
know like what days to put the shows up
and whatnot so yeah do you have to kind
of keep track of that kind of [ __ ] but
yeah I feel like yeah we drank a lot
last night watched what do you call it
Hills Have Eyes which Dominic sent us
that's probably gonna be our next movie
retrospective and then for some reason I
was like scrolling through the free to
watch movies on YouTube and on there was
the animated movie from the 80s the
secret of NIMH and I was like holy [ __ ]
man I haven't seen that since I was a
kid I wonder is it still good cuz I used
to I saw that movie like a million times
when I was growing up and I read the
book and everything and really loved it
and still pretty [ __ ] solid yeah I
couldn't like the animation is gorgeous
I had forgotten like how beautiful that
animation was yeah I forgot how how good
hand drawn at an drawn animation yeah
the voice acting was also terrific and
it was like it wasn't Disney it was a
Don Bluth I think he's the same guy that
did like an American tail and all those
kind of ones so it was for yeah it
wasn't it wasn't like a zany you know I
mean a little bit darker it was kind of
cool because you were saying about a
[ __ ] watership down and I said this
yeah I said this one's kind of late this
one's not as dark as that but it does
have a thing about animal
experimentation and deaths and stuff
like one it like you know one of the
rats gets like crushed by a [ __ ]
cement block and one gets killed by a
cat and that kind of stuff is this the
same cut no that was there's a German
one that was kind of like this about a
bunch of stray cats and yeah experiment
felidae belladona day that's right yeah
I haven't seen I've only seen bits and
pieces of money pretty more of it yeah I
think cat
yeah like I've to like on like puppet
strings and shoes yeah I've seen like
clips from it it looks pretty [ __ ] up
so I'm like amazed that I haven't seen
it but that's definitely one that I have
to check out but yeah so um when my
seeing watership down again though that
movie likes it that traumatized me when
I was a kid I read the book for the of
that one too when I was little I also
wouldn't mind seeing talk about
animation once I also wouldn't mind
seeing like the original Hobbit remember
the hobby yeah I really liked that I saw
it a bunch of times I remember liking it
as a kid I don't know how holds up I
didn't like the Lord of the Rings one as
much um I liked it but I haven't seen it
in a long time yeah but the Hobbit one
which wasn't [ __ ] who the hell was
that's not rankin/bass it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
now I can't remember the name of it but
yeah I really I remember really like him
like the ogre song and yeah the [ __ ] and
the voices and stuff it might be dumb I
don't know I haven't seen it since I was
a kid but I remember really digging it
oh and also since we're talking about
animation for a long time like when I
was a kid I grew up and I would see this
[ __ ] cartoon that was like it was
Jack and the Beanstalk was what it was
but it had like all these really weird
aspects to it like it had instead it had
the giant the Giants name was tulip and
but the giant had a mom who was like a
little bitty like witch named Madame
Hecuba and um it was just this really
really weird like but I loved it that
she was tracking the Beanstalk okay Jack
the Beanstalk and so Cuba kind of
reminded me of something else there was
like yeah there was like a Japanese
cartoon well this I didn't know it at
the time but this was Japanese it had
just been dubbed into English and I
wasn't aware of that I was a kid I
didn't know anything about like [ __ ]
anime or like Japanese anything and
there was also yeah those so there was
like this witch and then there was like
a princess and the witch was like
keeping the princess like under spell
and like making her like Mary the giant
so the witch could run the kingdom of
the clouds or whatever even though it
didn't look like anybody else was there
but um
it just had these really really great
like creepy sequences and then for a
long time like I saw it a million times
like on cable when I was growing up and
then later I would like tell other
people about it and they look at me like
I had [ __ ] underwear
I had like they didn't like you are
chirpin you'd like must've imagined that
but then one day I was like scroll I
said I'm gonna look for that [ __ ] so I
looked forward on YouTube and I found it
and I was like aha
see I didn't make it up but then that's
when I kind of like researched it and
found out that it was actually Japanese
and have been dubbed into English which
is why it had like all this really weird
[ __ ] in it you know what I mean yeah
because I think the witch turned out to
be spoiler alert
mechanical CSI boy it sounds like sounds
like something my vaguely remember but I
thought was called Magnificat no and it
was it was Japanese but it had been
dubbed into English and it didn't make
any [ __ ] sense I might be getting it
makes me mistaken for that one yeah I
think I've seen that as a kid this makes
sense it was Jack in the Beanstalk it
just had like all these other weird like
elements and everything I remember it
and I remember yeah in a robot or
something was a robot in there yeah yeah
she was like clockwork or medical or
something like the giant diner she was
yeah remember that it was just like a
really bizarre that one but there was
another one about miss Magnificat or
magnificant maybe that maybe that was a
character out of some kind of jab it
looked like a Western cartoon yeah I'm
from them from some from America like a
Walt Disney there was actually a
Japanese fake that's what this one was
too it was they were definitely trying
to look like didn't look like it but you
it still had like some in hindsight it
still had like a lot of Japanese of
Japanese like that you know the girl
with the big eyes and like the little
pointy hair so worried telling was like
Japanese yeah the crazy way they tell
stories yeah no just just all across it
across the board you know I mean there's
no real middle ending no no beginning
middle or end to the stories it's just a
bunch of stories yeah told in a string
this one it has this one had music to is
the music yeah it had songs and stuff
but it was like it was really creepy
it's really good actually there's more
than one of those and I remember him
probably I think they were trying to
like get into the reason e style market
and trying to like appeal to a wider
audience I wasn't first start appearing
like in the late 70s early 80s yeah
because I think this I think this Jack
and the Beanstalk when I looked it up I
think it came out
in 1977 is there something like I
remember they're like those crazy-ass
[ __ ] Russian movies yeah they tell
you this shit's in bad that's in bad
it's [ __ ] up in the north of ice and
[ __ ] yeah it's clearly Santa Santa
Claus and yes Santa Claus wait looks
like [ __ ] you got they're calling him
Sinbad but he's dressed like [ __ ]
Santa Claus
yeah that's up in the ice he's fighting
Baba Yaga [ __ ] a house with [ __ ] yeah
on it and [ __ ] chicken feet you know I
mean and you're like like a seven or
eight your mind is [ __ ] blown I
didn't know mad enough
who knew Sinbad this is also Santa Claus
he bought witches well Sinbad sensor
cloths you know yes I loved those Ray
Harryhausen send bad movies man yeah
send bad I the tiger Sinbad the [ __ ]
seven sin the sin badness it I just love
it my pretty ass little babysitter my
babies Jimmy yeah Kimmy okay I showed
her a picture kid I inherited a photo of
candy and she look like Princess Leia I
thought she was I thought she was
Princess Leia basically to me you know I
was a little kid she's driving around
hello was she in the photo Prime at 13
something like that yeah 13 and I just
thought she was just all all pretty
girls were at 10 when I was 7 or 8 yeah
they were all 10 it's like kind of neat
though like when you're a kid because
she's like because you haven't seen a
lot of people in your life 10 so it's
just like every time you see a pretty
girl you like you don't notice her it's
10 yeah she's as cute as I remembered
her though and it dug it out she's like
yeah yeah sure yes you sure look like a
young Princess Leia did she look like
Carrie Fisher though she did it yeah a
13 year old Carrie Fisher so yeah yeah
it was Russian movies they did a couple
of those on Mystery Science Theater
Jack Frost and sword and the dragon I
can't remember which one it was but they
did one what would their had where they
have MIT where there was like a Sinbad
e-type character but he wasn't like I
think it was called sword in the dark
Amy took me to see Sinbad
when she was a baby I saw Sinbad in the
eye of the tiger I'm pretty sure I saw
that in the theater but I don't think I
saw the other one back in the days when
we grew up you know what I mean
you had babysitter's here and really
what a babysitter was is that your mom
tossed you some to some teenage girls
well I was I was a teenager what and I
was the oldest of my siblings too yeah
okay so it was different for you so yes
I was an only child said you know the
maiden [ __ ] in my on my block was
nothing but teenage girls yeah you know
me my mom see here little baby Tom's
like I was [ __ ] big maybe Tom's
popular nice living doll
well you were a cute little kid yeah
needs to take me up there and to their
[ __ ] room they'd be putting on Led
Zeppelin houses of the Holy and [ __ ] and
smoking weed and [ __ ] and you'd be
like damn blacklight posters on and [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] on the blacklight posters
don't want baby tell Bogart yeah but
yeah oh I meant to do this yesterday and
I feel really bad um one of our patrons
and listeners Matthew who's in Australia
he had asked me yesterday to shout out
Anzac Day I guess that's how you
pronounce it which is kind of like the
Australian Memorial Day you know I mean
was you know the people that have died
in wars and stuff and I meant to do it
yesterday and then like we recorded the
sidetracks and five minutes later I was
like I forgot yeah so I said well I'll
do it today so happy late Anzac Day to
all our Australian listeners out there
the Australian Armed Forces served
alongside us [ __ ] with [ __ ] pride
and distinction in almost every major
theatre
wherever we were the Australians were
also there yeah even in Vietnam and I
don't know I brought this - it's a light
- uh - Sofa the other day I go on about
the Koreans people always talk about the
United States and Vietnam what a mistake
it was it wasn't
day goes [ __ ] stupid wait the way
they were trying to conduct that [ __ ]
over there and just the whole meaning
behind that I mean anyway a lot of
people don't know that there were more
Koreans in there fighting alongside us
than there were Americans hmm I didn't
know that either
there are certain times were more Korean
troops by a substantial margin than
there were Americans well that makes
sense it was the Koreans doing all the
heavy lifting and a lot of it had to do
they had a lot of advantage over
American troops you know I mean they
they weren't scared of Vietnam they were
a new army they were 100% backed and
funded by the US government so they work
and they were they were sending Korea's
best and at that time America wasn't
really wasn't sent at his best
they were just sending conscripts you
know guys who were drafted yeah
not Korea was taking volunteers you know
because that's was big money to be a
soldier in Korea so they were kind of
like a professional army the mercenaries
yeah basically is a good way to put it
and the [ __ ] Koreans they were
effective you'd send an American unit
out into an area to look for the enemy
they wouldn't find him you'd send the
Koreans in their [ __ ] the next day
they'd come out there with all kinds of
[ __ ] weapons and they'd find every
bit of that [ __ ] yeah yeah they knew
what they were doing they weren't us
they weren't afraid and they were
professionals the other thing the
American guys are most of them were just
trying to bide their time to get it yeah
they really weren't put a lot of effort
in what she can't really blame them yeah
it kind of got like suckered into yeah
they will ever forced right you had to
go a big difference in based on on the
back of that experience the United
States Army realized that you don't
really want conscripts no you want guys
that want to be that want to be theirs
and yes pay him well you know and then
contractors come into play and other
things that are like contractors so but
yeah Australia was there and probably
Australia probably [ __ ] probably is
similar to the Koreans in terms of they
were probably volunteers yeah cuz you
know maybe they weren't but it would be
more likely it had to go back and look
in history
be more likely that maybe they were
drafted into Australian service but you
probably had to like send me volunteer
for certain kind of units that went to
to Vietnam but you'd have to check yeah
yeah usually the pattern was is that
basically their fight in America's war
you know I mean so win or not when you
have an allied competent country fight
one of our Wars whether they don't
really like to draft some guys off the
damn street you know and say here go
over there and help fight America's war
they don't really like that yeah you
know they like to send some guy who's a
little more professional and just you
know it has a different he's getting
paid well yah I mean who wants to be
there for his career like a career move
yeah usually Special Forces type troops
is what you're talking about usually
yeah so what else we gonna talk about
probably nothing uh I wanted to say this
morning you came into my office this
morning and said cuz Pookie was being
cute this wall she's always being cute
but he said that yeah she went to like
you know we have the sliding glass doors
or whatever and there's like a blackout
curtain over it and she goes like
underneath the curtain so she can look
outside likely got into the backyard and
apparently she just said she didn't want
to go outside or anything like that she
was just sitting by the window looking
out and she was like talking to the
outside she wasn't yeah she wasn't
sitting he was laying in her back feet
up on the glass
yeah and you you hello
well I was never seen her do that I know
that's very weird I've never seen her do
that either it's like usually I mean
she'll like talk to you if you like
sometimes even talk to her she'll answer
you you know I said that this morning
she was like in the closet and she's
like sticking her butt up you know like
when you like Pat her and stuff and I
started because she would tell like he
was thinking copacabana's had even put
in pokey in there yeah and I guess so I
was thinking of like Barry Manilow or
Neil Diamond or her
the hell it is and I started singing
that song Mandy except with pokey yeah
and then you know so I just thought that
was really funny you came and you showed
me your bow that one yeah yeah I'm
pretty sure that's Barry Manilow right
because I don't know what fun fact
my sister Amanda is named after that
song okay and she hated that song so
much that she refuses to let anybody
call her Mandy to this day she she's
Amanda Amanda she doesn't like Mandy
because she just doesn't like that song
as she's mad
alright so you want to wrap up Sunday
alright so yeah we will talk to you guys
again tomorrow so everybody stays safe
and healthy out there see ya